I'm glad you're in a good mood let's get
right to the disasters she right I mean
Puerto Rico Las Vegas Donald Trump we
had a rough week and he does not make it
better you know you've heard that term
first responders he's he's got a new
thing worst responder
he's the we finally went to Puerto Rico
a week after the storm he said he would
have come earlier except his a
hairdresser told him it was too
dangerous plans on the island like Ponce
de Leon and you know the natives
immediately said can we have the
hurricane back and and then he asked
this meeting it says the first thing he
says I hate to tell you Puerto Rico but
you throw in our budget a little out of
whack
we spent a lot of money here in Puerto
Rico that he's so Trump I know you've
had the worst time ever in your whole
life let me just pull up your account
then he calls the mayor we're just
asking for help a nasty woman and throws
paper towels to the crowd and then he
says instead a real catastrophe like
Katrina and they said well you're not a
real president like Obama
[Applause]
[Music]
so are you
you're starting to see a pattern that
the most important thing that has to
happen when there's a disaster is Trump
being praised the other thing he said
soon as he hit the ground in Puerto Rico
the governor says giving us very high
grades if we get just somehow harness
his ego we could power the entire island
[Applause]
today he said he's really starting to
question whether the people of Puerto
Rico fully understand and appreciate the
extent of his suffering you know like a
joke but what happened never mind
so then he goes on Twitter to whine how
the no good mean fake news media spoiled
his great day in Puerto Rico yeah they
pulled that fake news dirty trick they
always do with a videotape him doing
exactly what he does and says and then
show it on TV you know that dirty trick
so
[Applause]
so the next day his no empathy tour
rolls into Las Vegas where he tells them
that they're lucky that it's not worse
and more people didn't die you know
first of all I'm so sick of all the
reactions I'm so sick of thoughts and
prayers
first of all thoughts are the opposite
of prayers
a thought is what should I do a prayer
is wishing on a star thoughts and
prayers of the Republican way of saying
tough [ __ ] yeah I hear this a lot on TV
this week you know what do we tell the
children
how about we're moving to Canada right
now we're still here don't forget that
no Roger stone you know Trump's albino
assassin Oh Roger
he said if Trump even thinks about doing
something about gun control the quote
base will go insane that is not enough
to make you get your pets dear leader
had dinner the other night with the
military chiefs and at the end of it he
said this could be the calm before the
storm and people what are we talking but
you know people and he said you'll find
out yes tune in next week for next
exciting episode of the edge of madness
we'll North Korea get a bomb or a rose
we don't know
come before the storm it could mean
anything either he's about to start a
war or he ate too many prunes at dinner
either
Rex Tillerson is so right did you see
that Rex Tillerson the Secretary of said
our top diplomat called him a [ __ ] is
that tonight in fact he said they dug a
little deeper and found out he actually
called a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and now this country now they're
debating that whether he said [ __ ] or
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I say ask Melania if anybody knows about
[ __ ] Morra